Hello everybody!
I'm sorry for being late!
Hello!
Oh my god, I hate being late.
I'm so sorry.
I always... I hate being late.
I'm really sorry guys, because you gave up your personal time to like, make sure I start on time.
And today I didn't start on time.
I'm really, really sorry guys.
Um, I've been doing a lot... I've been going outside a lot.
Um, the last... Okay, a lot as in like the last...
Yesterday and today.
Yesterday and today, um, I have to go outside to do some errands.
Um, because, uh, I'm finally well enough to actually go outside.
Other than walking my dog.
Because, uh, you guys didn't know.
You guys didn't know.
I've been like, sick the last, uh, couple of months.
And I've been like, back-to-back-to-back sick.
And because I've been like, back-to-back-to-back sick, I haven't been able to do a lot of errands that I need to do that require me to go out.
More than just walking my dog.
So, the last two days, I've been catching up on like, going to the bank, um, buying some things that I needed to buy.
Regarding like, work-related stuff.
Doing work... Doing work-related things that I had to do that required me to go outside.
Um, so, but today, I sort of, like, came home, uh, late.
Because I woke up late.
But I still had to do my errands today.
So, like, even though, like, I woke up late, I still had to go out, uh, and like, do things I had to do.
Oh, fuck, okay.
I'm sad.
Okay, so, wait, let me double-check if this is a thing that's- if this is a store that's worldwide.
Before I accidentally, like, dox my-my, like, city or something.
I need to know.
Is this, like, okay, uh, let me- I just need to know, like, how many stores are there of this particular- Okay, okay, um...
Okay, okay, that's cool.
Okay, it's all around Canada.
Okay, that's cool.
Anyway!
So, I was getting some prints made.
I was also, like, testing some prints out.
And this was for, like, uh, this was for, like, the, uh, charity.
Uh, this was for, like, the charity auction from last year.
So, I'm sending extra-sized prints to everybody that, uh, won prints from me.
And I was testing out London Drugs, uh, just to be, like- I'm also getting them made at another print store.
But I wanted to see if London Drugs have, like, uh, good quality, uh, prints as well.
So, uh, but the thing is, I'm also getting it done by a local- a local print shop as well.
But I wanted to see- because, like, London Drugs is fast, so I was testing it out as well.
So, I was picking that up today, too.
Um, London Drugs- yes, I know.
It's a- basically, like, a retail pharmacy store.
So, you can- you know, like, I don't know the equivalent of that in America.
Uh, but it's, like, a little- it's, like, a pharmacy store, but it has, like, compu- you can buy, like, uh, everything- you can buy anything there.
Um, like, basically, it has everything.
And I didn't realize on the back side of the print, it just says, London Drugs.
What?
Yeah, it's like a- oh, okay, yeah, it's like CVS Walgreens.
So, on the back side of these prints, it says, London Drugs!
Photo Lab!
Go to our website to get more photos!
And I was like, okay, I'm not- I'll send the- whoever gets these ones, I'll give you guys these for- I'm gonna give those for free.
But, like, I'm not gonna do this for the- I don't know, I don't know if the other- maybe I'll do it, I'll just be like, sorry about that, I was testing out different print stores.
And- So, I'll give these out for free.
So, yeah, it's, like, the first one's free, guys.
It literally gives, like, the website's like, visit www.londondrugs.com.
And I'm like, aw, that sucks.
I'm like, aw, why does it- why do that?
They're really nice quality, too, I'm really sad.
These are actually really nice quality, and I'm like, aw.
Only it doesn't say, go to London Drugs to get more photos done.
But, yeah, so, yeah, I've been, like, I've just been- I'm making, like, additional prints for those who won the charity auctions for the prints and stuff.
And everything, and just cause, like, different sizes of them.
So, just to be like, sorry it took so long and everything.
Also shipped out more postcards today.
And everything.
Also, psychos, thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
I'm glad that Kony died and cleared up your sickness and you're able to go outside and touch grass now.
Thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
Uh, lollipop, thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
There's a print from the cum with a free bit and knife, too.
Thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
But, yeah, so, yeah, I've been, like, that's why I've been late.
I had to do a lot of stuff, I had to do bank stuff, too.
I did bank stuff yesterday, but, um, I couldn't finish the things I had to do at the bank.
I had to go again tomorrow to ship out more things.
And also, um, I needed to go to the bank tomorrow again.
Because I didn't go to the bank today, I went to the bank yesterday.
Because today I didn't have time to go to the bank.
Uh, because it takes a long, I won't say how long it takes me to walk to the areas I need to walk to.
But, like, I keep forgetting how long it takes me to walk to the places I have to go to.
Because I was like, I should be back in time.
I was not back in time.
Obviously, I was not back in time.
I always underestimate how long it takes me to get home.
Of course you can!
Yeah, happy birthday!
Anyway, so, um, yeah, that's why it took me so long to get back.
I also had to, uh, uh, I just had a lot of stuff to catch up on in general.
Um, and, like, another thing was that, okay, this is why I'm a mess.
So, like, I got into a, um, a 30-minute lecture from my manager.
Because they were like, you need to check your incoming wire transfers for the stuff you do.
Because, like, we need to, like, actually check if you're getting paid.
And I was like, oh, you mean, like, they might not pay me?
And they were like, uh, we don't know if, like, they actually paid you or not because you don't check.
And I was like, oh.
And then I looked at my, and I was, like, looking through my wire transfers coming in.
And then, like, from November, I was like, I don't know what's what.
And my manager was like, this is exactly why you have to be checking.
And I was like, oh.
Oh, my God.
And they were like, dude, you might be working for free.
And I was like, wait, you mean they might not send me the money?
So, so, so, like, we were, like, we were, because, like, for those who've never had done wire transfers before, or, like, received wire transfers, you don't see who sent, you don't see who sent you the money online.
You can't, it's just numbers.
And then, so, like, I, you know, I have a lot of them because I've done a lot of, like, deals.
I've done a lot of sponsors.
I've done a lot of brand deals.
I've done a lot of, like, a lot of, like, merch and stuff like that.
So, like, there was a lot.
But then, we don't know what correlates with what because I never kept up with it.
So, like, we were trying to figure it out by just the money being sent in.
And so, like, but, like, obviously, that's really difficult because we don't know.
So, then, tomorrow, I have to go to a bank and, like, be like, can I have, like, the names of everybody that sent me wire transfers since November?
So, we can tell.
We can, like, contact the people who we've done, like, stuff with and then be like, hey, I haven't been paid yet, you know?
Like, I'm gonna be like, hey, um, so, you remember, like, the sponsor I did in November?
Um, yeah, so, like, I just checked and I might not, I don't think I've been paid yet.
So, I need to confirm to see if I have been or not.
Yeah, I'm gonna start checking my accounts regularly, like, for it.
Um, and so, like, just to be sure that, just to be sure I'm getting paid for things I'm doing.
There's a lot of, the thing is, there's a lot of transactions.
I have been receiving a lot of wire transfers in.
So, I don't know which is for what.
Like, uh, Juan George, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
The first jokey may also be free.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Uh, Nexy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Aphelion, thank you for the five gifted shoes, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, so, I'm learning.
I'm, guys, I'm learning, guys.
I'm fucking learning right now.
Every day is a new experience.
Also, I was gonna tell this story.
I told members I was gonna tell this story in a public stream.
Because, like, I didn't, I was like, oh, this story, I can't, guys, I can't tell this on a member stream.
Because it's a, it's a, it's a universal story.
Alright, give me a sec, guys.
I also just, um, boiled some water, so let me get some water real quick before I start the story, because I'm dehydrated.
I'll be right back.
Also, guys, I bought vitamins.
I actually, guys, guys.
I bought vitamins, guys.
Alright, listen to this.
I got Omega-3.
Because it says, it helps reduce cholesterol and promote heart health.
So I got, I'm taking them now.
I'm an adult, I got Omega-3.
It's a pill.
Okay, sorry, the water's too hot for me to drink too much of it, so.
It's a giant-ass fucking pill.
Take one of four soft gels daily.
Store it between, I hope this is 15 to 25 degrees.
Pills here.
A Zelda, thank you for 50 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
I also got D3.
You hear that?
Which supports a healthy immune system and bone health.
And I'm pretty sure, like, that's for the sunlight, right?
Because I do not get enough sunlight for sure.
So I got D3.
And then, I got chewables for vitamin C.
Which supports a healthy immune system.
So, look at that, guys.
I'm actually looking- Look, every day, I level- I gain, like, 1 XP.
You guys, you adults out there, you might be, like, level 50 right now.
And I might be, like, level 10.
But every day, I'm getting there, guys.
Every-
Every day, I'm getting there.
I'm getting better and better.
Every- Every day.
Tabby, thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Chat, what do I eat for dinner?
Carbonara or soup?
Carbonara, for sure.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your very first super chat, too.
Void Time, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doesn't matter.
That's just Doki.
Just- Oh, wait.
Doesn't matter.
Where's the Flintstone tablets?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, do I need to take iron supplements?
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know.
I literally just- I looked at- I was at the London Drugs.
I looked at the table of, like, the rows of vitamins.
And I was just, like- I remember- I remember Omega-3.
Because my mom used to, like, be like- Eat more fish- More fish so you get more Omega-3.
And shit like that.
So, like, I was like- I don't eat enough fish.
Maybe I should- Oh, if you bleed?
Oh, I don't bleed.
So, like, I should be fine, right?
I don't go outside enough to, like- Be in danger of bleeding.
Okay, so I just don't- So, I don't need to take iron then.
So, that's just for the lack of blood.
Uh...
Let's see.
Out of context!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just a- It's a Flintstone gummies.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Did you see that?
The last Sniper Elite game has an invasion mode that resembles those games?
No, I haven't.
I think the only Sniper Elite game I played was the one where I shot Hitler in the balls.
Which is, like, all of them.
Ha!
I'm sorry.
Which is basically all- All of them are like that.
Now that I think about it.
Sorry, sorry.
Correction.
In the one singular ball.
That got me so- Okay, anyway.
Story time!
So, like, um...
I was getting, um...
I was getting, like, bullied by one of my friends.
Friends?
Like, friend.
My singular friends.
That I have.
Um, because they were like, How much do you go outside?
Like, what's your step count?
Um, and then- Like, what's your step count?
And then I was like, I don't know, I don't have an Apple Watch.
And so they were like, Yeah, but, like, you take your dog out for walkies, right?
Like, so, like, your phone does that.
Your phone also, like, counts your- Uh, counts your steps.
And so, I was like, You know, sometimes I don't bring my phone out.
When I do walkies.
Cause, like, sometimes, um...
The reason why I don't bring my phone out sometimes when I do the walks.
Is that, uh...
Uh...
Sometimes it's gonna be a really quick walk.
Cause, uh...
Dad just- Sometimes just wants to pee and poop and go home.
Like, that's literally it.
And so...
So, sometimes I just don't bring it.
Because there's no point.
I was just like, I just go downstairs.
I just go downstairs.
Take him out.
And then just let him poop and pee.
And then...
And then go home.
Like...
That's really it.
Um...
And then...
So, my friend was like, That's fucking crazy.
That you don't bring out your phone all the time.
Even when you're outside.
Um...
Because, like, What if there's an emergency?
Like, what if, like, you know, something happens to you?
And then I was like, Uh...
Doki can protect me.
Doki Amber Doge can protect me.
And then my friend was like, Are you fucking crazy?
What is he gonna do?
They're like, What the fuck is he gonna do?
He's...
He's so...
He's tiny.
And I was like, Well, I...
Well...
I was like, Well, if I'm getting...
They're like, What if they robbed you?
And then so I was like, Well, If they're gonna rob me, They're gonna take my phone.
So, I was like, What was the point of me bringing my phone?
And they're just gonna rob me and take it.
And so, So, So, like, That was...
So, I was just like, Yeah, like, What's the point?
And then, And then my friend was like, Okay, but what if there's an emergency?
And there was an accident?
And like, You are, like, The only person there, As a bystander, Watch...
That saw this accident that happened.
And you need to call the...
The...
Call, like, 911.
And then I was like, Well, I guess...
Sucks to be them that I was the only person there.
Like, I'm just like, I guess I'll just walk around and find someone to...
I'll just...
I was like, I guess I'll, like, Use their phone.
I don't know.
They might have a phone.
Guess I'll just die.
And then...
And I was just like, Well, maybe I'll...
Maybe they'll have the phone.
Or like, what if they don't have the phone?
Then I was just like, Well, Well, if they don't have the phone, Maybe I'll walk around and find someone that will.
Like, it doesn't have to be my phone.
And...
Like, I don't know.
Someone else can make the call.
Why is it up to me?
Just bring your phone.
No!
I've been doing this for so long and nothing bad has happened yet.
Just bring the damn phone.
This is genuinely...
I just don't do it all the time.
Sometimes I bring my phone.
Sometimes I don't.
Like, I feel like it's not the end of the world.
It's not.
Like, Sometimes it's just walkies.
It's...
It's just walkies.
I literally...
It's so close.
The fucking area for him to pee and poop is so close.
And there's people around me.
Like, what's gonna happen to...
Oh man, I'm gonna say that and then something's gonna happen to me today.
Dad has too much aura.
He's the alpha.
Dad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The walkie could be your last.
Not the jinx.
If I'm gonna get kidnapped, what the fuck is a phone gonna do for me?
What is it gonna do?
They're gonna take my phone anyway.
Don't say...
Now something will definitely happen.
Wait, okay.
Knock on...
Is this wood?
I don't know.
Yeah, this is wood.
Knock on wood.
I have it turned off.
Oh, I should turn it on.
Yeah, but what if they take my phone and break it?
I feel like if I'm getting kidnapped, the first thing they'll do is be like, Oh my god, she might have her phone on her and have the track on location thing.
So like, they'll just take my phone and destroy it.
I mean, that's kidnapping 101.
You know what?
If I was a kidnapper, the first thing I'd do is destroy their phone.
Because...
Destroy their phone and then throw it away.
Like, if I was a kid...
Not all kidnappers are smart.
I feel like if you're gonna kidnap somebody, you must have planned it out.
They would just pick something.
They would just be like, today I feel like kidnapping something right now.
Their impulsive thoughts came out and was like, you know what?
I'm gonna do it today.
She has thought about this.
No, I literally thought, I literally came up with that within one minute of talking about it.
You overestimate the intelligence of criminals.
I'm just saying, I'm just saying.
I feel like, I feel like a kidnapper would not just randomly decide to kidnap somebody out of the blue with zero planning.
Especially in my neighborhood.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki knows a little too much about kidnapping.
We're worrying for the wrong person.
She is the danger.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, also, I'm gonna tell you guys about what I was like really sad about.
Because, okay, so, I told this in the member stream.
I told this in the member stream, but like, at London Drugs, they have this thing called a confessional, a desktop confessional.
They have like a bunch of stuff, they have like desktop whatever.
So it's like these miniature things on your, on your table.
And cause I was like, what the fuck are these tiny boxes?
So like, so, I thought it was really fun, cause, and they had one that was called desktop confessional.
Now I'm so curious, I was like, the fuck is that?
And, so, I'm gonna read the backside.
So, in the front it says, you are forgiven.
And I was like, oh my god, what the fuck?
Like, is this like a miniature confessional?
Like, at your desk?
So, this is what it says in the back.
Tell me your sins.
Gain absolution from the comfort of your home with desktop confessional.
This mini confessional booth features a light-up screen, pressure-activated kneeler, and a holy voice that prompts you to share your sins before offering a comforting, you are forgiven.
So, I was like, oh my god, I can have a mini confessional to forgive me for every sin I commit on stream.
So, I was like, oh my god, that's fucking hilarious.
So, I bought it.
And, like, I took it out during the meme stream.
Because I just wanted to hear this holy voice go, you are forgiven.
Like, that's all I wanted to hear.
And, like, and it's broken.
It doesn't work.
The thing lights up, but there's no holy voice that tells me I'm forgiven.
I was so sad.
And so, like, I don't know if this is broken or a lie to me.
I was like, please, forgive me.
Why would they not forgive my sins?
You are not.
Okay, so I showed pictures of it.
So, this is, oh shit, sorry, this is a big picture.
So, like, this is what it looks like.
So, there's a, it's like tiny as fuck and I thought it was really funny.
So, like, there's the confessional.
So, behind this blank, behind this is a little window that lights up when you press the...
It, like, lights up when you press, like, the little bench thing.
And, like, here's the window of this.
And this is, like, the window.
So, like, it lights up and I just want it to forgive me.
So, like, I was like, I'm going back tomorrow.
I'm gonna buy another one.
I need to know...
I need to know if the voice works.
I just...
Everything else works.
It lights up, by the way.
It fucking lights up.
But, like, that's it.
No forgiveness.
You can't force forgiveness.
So, I'm going back tomorrow and trying to...
I'm buying another desktop confessional.
Just to see if it actually tells me if I'm forgiven or not.
Because it literally says...
A holy voice that prompts you to share your sins before offering and comforting you are forgiven.
Like, I...
Why is it not comforting me?
Like...
No mercy for the sinner.
It doesn't...
I don't understand.
Why won't it comfort me?
I just want you to comfort me and tell me I'm forgiven.
You confess your sins.
You need to go to an actual church.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's almost as if you got scammed by a scam product.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mr. Stan, thank you for the super chat.
Even gods must pay for their sins, don't they?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It doesn't forgive me and I don't know why.
Like, everything else works.
It lights up.
So, yeah, I'm going back.
I have to do more errands tomorrow anyway because I need to go to the bank.
There's a London Drugs nearby.
Not nearby.
It's still a walk away.
So, I need to go to another...
I need to go there and buy another confessional desk.
Stop confessional.
Repent.
Why do I feel like repenting today?
Like, how can I do it in the comfort of my own home?
Like, this is what it's for.
I just want to...
I just want to repent in the comfort of my own home.
I think the reasoning was that you would hear that you are forgiving inside you.
Not from the toy.
But it says a holy voice that prompts you to share your sins.
Where is this holy voice?
Where is it?
It even has a picture that says you are forgiven.
Okay, I'm going to take a picture of this.
I'm going to...
I'm going to take a picture of this, guys.
I need you guys to see, like, what I see and why I feel like I should be forgiven.
I need you guys to know.
It says for ages 14 and up.
How come a 14...
Why can't a 13-year-old confess?
I don't understand.
Why is it age-restricted?
Wait, what?
Why?
Why is my fucking desktop confessional age-restricted to, like, 14 and up?
That I don't...
13-year-olds have to go in person.
I don't understand.
They're not...
So they have to go in person.
Alright, I'm going to show you guys.
I'm going to show you guys what I see.
And why I believe I should be able...
Why I believe it's built into this fucking thing.
Okay, give me a sec.
Alright, so this is literally what I saw.
And I was like, I'm going to buy this.
Like, literally, desktop confessional, you are forgiven!
It literally tells me that I am forgiven.
Why won't you forgive me?
And then, this is...
This is the back side.
This is the back side of it.
Tell me your sins.
Gain absolution from the comfort of your home with desktop confessional.
This mini confessional booth features ages 14 and up.
Did you tell it your sins?
You can download a sound byte saying you are forgiven for free.
Also, the review says some of them are broken out of the...
Are you fucking kidding me?
I can't believe it!
Being forgiven is RNG?
Thank you for the super chat, Paladins.
I can't believe being forgiven is based on gotcha.
That's so fucked up.
I lost.
Doki was not forgiven.
Never forgiven.
Anyway, I'm buying another one.
I'm going to test my luck and buy another desktop confessional.
I'm going to test my gotcha roll.
And see if I can...
I still don't understand why they age restricted it.
Why 14?
Do 13-year-olds just don't understand?
Don't get scammed again.
Alright, for anyone that super chats...
How much was it?
That super chats?
$13?
I will buy another confessional in your name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki's sins are so heavy to be forgiven by the desktop version.
Please upgrade the version.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who's confessing in that tiny confessional booth?
Remy, Stuart, LittleBae, and I don't know why, but I can see TomatoDoki trying to wedge herself into the booth.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You are forgiven.
Alright, go for it.
Medi and Cas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, I'll buy another one.
Just for you, dragons.
I'll buy another one.
That's alright.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for enabling my confessional gotcha.
Next scene, Nara, Neppers, and Frozen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why am I doing this?
LaughingMan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Better get to...
Oh my god.
That's a lot of desktop content.
Buy a whole desktop chair.
Bro, I just want them to tell me that I'm forgiven.
That's all I want.
They're gonna have like...
This website's gonna have a surge of sales from us.
Just cause we all wanna test out our gotcha luck at getting forgiven.
LaughingMan She can buy a tent pole now.
Buy the whole set.
I'm so sad.
LaughingMan Literally, that was the only reason why I bought this.
I wanted a holy voice to forgive me.
LaughingMan Thank you, everybody, for the super chat.
Thank you.
Game, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't think of a better way to spend money.
Go get a better one, Turkey, please.
The rest doesn't count.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
LaughingMan There will soon be forgiveness.
Just not today.
LaughingMan Thank you.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, guys.
It's time to ask...
Anyway.
That is my life update for today.
I had to do a lot of outside.
I had to touch grass a lot.
So that is my life update.
Anyway, let us play.
Also, PlaceboBuddy and NickName, thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, gosh.
Guys, my confessional is so popular.
LaughingMan Look, everybody wants their own desktop confessional, guys.
But thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can get at least one that works.
LaughingMan I mean, it's a good idea.
It's such a good idea.
The amount of sin I commit every stream.
I just thought it'd be every time I do something bad.
I can literally get forgiven by my own personal desktop confessional.
LaughingMan I can get forgiven live on stream.
LaughingMan It's a good idea.
LaughingMan Anyway, guys.
That's not what we're going to play.
That's not my neighbor.
So, only if it works.
This really is the most Catholic thing I have ever seen.
Minimaxing your sins.
LaughingMan Anyway, guys.
LaughingMan Today, we are playing That's Not My Neighbor.
So, apparently, this game has come out a long time ago.
LaughingMan But it was on Ichigo.
I believe that's what...
I believe...
That's what...
What was it?
In the...
When you put...
Sorry, my brain is still frazzled up by my not working desktop confessional.
I'm still thinking about my fucking desktop confessional.
And not being forgiven for my sins.
LaughingMan I'm still thinking about it.
How am I that bad of a...
LaughingMan How much sin have I fucking committed that a miniature confessional would not forgive me?
LaughingMan Too...
Too much.
LaughingMan Anyway.
Sin is way heavy on the...
God has abandoned me.
LaughingMan Psalm 51 for the win.
LaughingMan LaughingMan You need to actually go to church.
With the amount of sin you've committed.
I need to go to Vatican City.
Just to be fully forgiven.
LaughingMan Okay.
Anyway.
Um...
So, this game was first released in Ichigo.
And...
Uh...
It was very popular.
I believe.
Amongst, like, the community.
And...
I've never actually played the game before.
I've never played the game when it was first, like, on, like, Ichigo.
Cause now it's on Steam.
And I think they added a lot of, uh, new content.
And...
Um...
The only thing I know about it was that everybody was...
All the...
Well, I wouldn't say, like, all the girls.
Cause, like, you know, some men could be also interested.
But, like, everyone was obsessed with a character called the Milkman.
And then I looked up the Milkman.
Cause I was like, why?
Cause I saw it on, like, YouTube Shorts and stuff.
People were making, like, animations about the Milkman.
And, you know, he obviously...
Artist's interpretation of the Milkman was really hot.
I was like, oh shit.
Like...
Like, I was like, damn.
Is the Milkman, like...
That should look like that?
Cause there were a lot of fanart about the Milkman.
So, I was really...
I was like, oh shit.
Let me...
Okay, I'll show you guys.
I literally googled Milkman.
Um...
That's not my neighbor.
And this was actually the first drawing that, like...
That came up on Google.
Like, the third.
Sorry, the third drawing that came up on Google.
So, he looked like that.
I was like, holy fuck.
Like, does he actually look like that?
I was so...
I was like, oh my god.
No wonder people are...
So obsessed with the Milkman in this game.
And so, like...
I was curious then.
I was like, alright then.
Let me google the Milkman.
And see what he actually looks like.
So, I googled him.
And he looks like this.
And I was like...
I was like...
I was just like...
He's just a tired man.
That's literally some...
Bro, he's just tired from his job.
I was like, oh, okay.
And I was like...
So, I was like...
I was like, oh, okay.
So, maybe he has a big part in the game.
Like, in the game itself.
So, that's why people are super obsessed with the Milkman.
But he doesn't.
He's just like...
The only...
I guess like...
I looked at the...
Like, in the game, from what I've read.
Is that...
Is that he's the only normal dude in the game.
So, like, everybody just latched on to him.
Because he's technically the most attractive looking one in the game.
Like, from what I've read.
That's why people are obsessed with him.
Because this guy is the most attractive one in the entire game.
And I'm like, but he's just some dude.
He's just some dude tired from his fucking Milkman job.
The winner by default.
Yeah, in a room full of freaks.
Also, another thing I know about...
Women love a man in a uniform, doki.
Ah, yes.
Tale as old...
Tale as old as time.
The Milkman that comes to your home in the 1940s.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
I hope...
I hope the husband doesn't know about the Milkman.
It's just ingrained in everybody.
Doki is shushed.
Wow.
People just want to bring back the Milkman in the 1940s.
No wonder you want to repent.
Moncler, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tired or not, I'm Milkmanning it.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, another thing I know about That's Not My Neighbor.
Is that it's basically like Papers, Please.
But like, for your apartment.
So that's basically the context I got from the game.
And it has a really, really good fan song.
And the song, it's been stuck in my head for a long time.
I actually wanted to make an animation meme based on it.
Because there's an animation meme based on it.
It's called Open The Door.
It has such a fucking catchy hook.
And I remember when the first song first came out.
When I first found out about the song.
I was so obsessed with it.
Because I saw a lot of animation memes with this song.
And it's just, I don't know.
I just love the hook.
The hook is so good.
Where they start bashing the window.
I'll link the song.
So this is the song, you guys want to listen to it.
But that's been stuck in my head all the time.
Maybe I'll make an animation meme about it in the future.
Because the Doki Bites have been put on hiatus for a while now.
Because I've been super busy with everything else.
I don't have time to approve stuff.
So whenever I bring back the Doki Bites.
I might put that in as one request I want to make.
Let's actually play the game.
I might not be forgiven today.
But I'm not going to stop committing sins.
But that's not going to stop me.
Alright, let's go.
That's not my neighbor.
I'm going to speak Spanish.
We know.
That's the spirit, Doki.
It hasn't stopped me before.
That's why you weren't forgiven.
Play, record, settings.
Alright, what are the settings here?
Sound.
Alright, let me make sure I can see what Sound Guy says.
Later.
Aspect ratio.
What's this?
Oh, develop.
Oh, that's what it is.
Text for important sounds.
Large dialog box.
Sensor elements.
Turn off flashing lights.
That's fine.
Dial phone with keyboard numbers.
Wait, do I have to actually dial the phone?
Nah, that's fine.
We'll see it.
We'll see how it goes.
That's a real quote from my OC.
Alright.
Play.
The DDD requests that you complete the following training to apply for the position of doorman.
Okay, yeah, sure.
I'll do a tutorial.
How bad can it be?
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Milkman is a friend to all housewives.
He brings the good stuff.
Oh, and milk too, I guess.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The following short film is a production of the DDD for educational purposes.
Okay.
Whoa.
Hello.
If you are watching this short film, it's because you are the new doorman of your building.
Oh wait, there was an Akasupa earlier.
I'm so sorry.
Zelda, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi Doki, love your content, your podcast, and all my draw sessions.
It's my birthday soon, but I won't be able to see it live then.
If I get a happy birthday, I'll be really happy.
That would be useless against a woman thief for sure.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Of course, Zelda.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Zelda.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Okay, your job is to determine whether a person requesting entry is a doppelganger or not.
As we all know, doppelgangers have the ability to take on someone's appearances and impersonate them.
But some are not very good at it, and it may create imperfections.
You must pay close attention to the physical appearances of your neighbors.
You cannot overlook any detail because that could result in your death or the death of your neighbors.
I mean, one neighbor dead is fine, right?
It's a three strike thing.
As long as there's not three bodies, it should be fine.
Your job and everything, and anyway, who likes all their neighbors anyway?
Your job is very important, so make sure you do it well.
Lastly, we congratulate the doorman of the month, Henry.
Not because he did an excellent job, but because he was the only doorman in the area who was not killed by doppelgangers.
Wait, why'd he leave?
Be like Henry.
But better.
You can see why the milkman was like, the most sought after guy in this whole game now, right?
Alright.
Welcome and congratulations on your new job.
Thank you.
As you saw in the short film, your job is to verify the entry of the tenants of this building.
Now explain how your office works.
First, you're two out of ten in a world full of one out of ten!
Holy fuck!
First, you need to know the information about each tenant.
Inside this folder, you have all the information you need.
Go ahead and open the folder and take a note.
Oh no, there's so much reading.
Alright, where's the milkman?
There he is!
Let's talk to him!
Let's go!
We know where he lives!
Ladies, ladies, ladies!
Now we know where Francis Mosses lives!
Or as we like to call it, the milkman.
It's him!
Alright, so these are all our neighbors.
I mean, nah, no, yeah, no.
Francis, the milkman, is actually the two other tenants.
Out of all of them.
And move the mouse to change it to close the paper.
Use the right click.
Okay.
The next... I kinda see it now!
Not so dead full.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My dad always hated the milkman, but I liked him.
He looked a lot like me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The next thing you need to check is the list of tenants that are supposed to request entry for the day.
This is today's list.
Please take the list and take a look.
Okay, just press the middle mouse button on photos in the list to mark them.
Oh, so if they already came in.
Okay.
Applicants must provide an identification card issued by the DDD.
This is a sample identification card.
You must verify name, number, expiration date, photograph, and logo.
Okay.
Name, expiration... so every... all the text.
Oh, so the DDD.
Okay, I got it.
It looks like that.
Arrow up.
Alright.
I got it.
In addition to identification, applicants must provide a sealed entry request issued by the DDD.
This is the sample entry request.
Go ahead and take it and take a look.
Authorized by the DDD for the training of new employees.
Doki got high standards.
MrBrokenBot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, reason, apartment number, full access.
Okay.
During the review process, you may need to contact an apartment in the building.
For this, you can use the phone in front of you.
Pick up the phone and dial the number.
Coding, you wish to dial and move the mouse.
Okay.
There you go.
You can interrogate the alleged tenant at any time.
Go ahead, ask me a question.
Appearance.
Here, the alleged tenant will give you the answer to your question.
For each applicant, you must fill out a checklist.
It's important that you complete it correctly as the list evaluates your performances.
Oh, bring the music down?
Okay, please take a checklist and complete the information as you like, as this is a sample.
Okay, so yep, yep, yep.
Yep.
Once the checklist is archived, you can decide whether to allow the applicant entry or not.
Go ahead and press any button.
Okay.
If at any time you determine that the applicant is a double-ganger, you must press the emergency button.
There is a reason why it is under a security box.
Once you press the button, there is no turning back.
When you press the button, you must wait for the cleaning protocol to be executed.
Once completed, you may continue with your work.
Very well!
Congratulations!
Yay!
I did it!
The bare minimum!
I bet it pays minimum wage.
There's no way.
I feel like I don't even need a degree for this.
Successfully completed the job training program for the passionate position.
I mean, it's literally a doorman.
I bet I got paid minimum wage.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, I can save it as a PNG, guys.
Save a PNG.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna...
You know what?
I'm gonna put it in my room.
Actually, let me...
Let me save this, actually.
What if I just print it out and put it on my wall?
Just have it framed.
They're like, oh my god, Duke, is that your college degree?
No, it's my job training certificate.
But that's not my neighbor.
Put it beside the desktop confessional.
Alright.
Let me adjust the...
Let me adjust the music real quick.
I'm gonna do it.
You think I won't?
I'm gonna put it in game and in my background.
Alright, I'll turn the music down.
Alright, let's go.
Let's play the first level.
Alright, the true experience of a work week as a building store man.
How bad can it be?
Hello.
What's on today's list?
You look pretty normal.
Okay.
What?
Alright, the DDD protects us.
Hundreds of doppelgangers are successfully eliminated every day.
Tensions at the border.
Allied countries are fearful of suspicious movements from enemy countries.
How much longer will this artificial peace last?
Clown movement.
Strange individuals wearing clown masks are distributing pamphlets throughout the city.
You're completely harmless.
Oh, and then there's missing person.
Titor!
Oh no, not Titor.
Alright.
Oh, he was just a news guy.
Oh, I thought... Okay.
Good afternoon.
Wait, is that her?
Wait, why you look different?
What happened to your hair, Miss Illinois?
Wait, you're not on the list.
Wait a minute.
You're not on the list.
Maya?
The fuck are you?
F-O-3-O-1?
You're not even on this list.
F-O-3-O-O-1.
Maya Stone?
Wait, you're not on the list.
Who let you outside?
Who the fuck let you outside?
It's the weekend, lady.
You only go to school and come home.
Today's list, yeah.
It's Saturday.
What kind of work emergency would you have?
That's sus.
Okay, let's see.
That's suspicious as hell.
Okay, 7, 8, when's your birthday?
Oh, you're right, I should call her.
7, 8, 9.
Guys, 7, 8, 9.
Guys, do I have to write her phone number down?
Okay.
Wait, what's this expiration date?
I don't know where I put it.
What date is it today?
I'm coming from my job as a teacher.
1, 4, 2, 5.
Wait, how do you- Oh shit, there you go.
I thought I had to dial the actual- 1, 4, 2, 5.
Pick up the phone.
Oh my god.
This is Maya speaking.
Roommate?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
You're not Maya.
You're a doppelganger!
Get out!
That's fucking right!
Imposter!
Yay!
See, look at that.
Get her out of here.
How dare she trick me.
Lock her up.
Okay, okay.
You're on the list, Margaret.
Maya, you're looking awfully happy today.
I'm a resident of the building.
My apartment is 03- Oh my god, there's so much information.
Second floor.
Okay.
You are Margaret Bubbles.
What's your identity card?
1-0-3-2-6-8-0-1-4.
Wait, what date is it today?
1917- Wait, what?
It's 1955.
Wait, it's 1955?!
Why is your- Oh shit, maybe the ID card expires late.
I don't know.
I mean, like, I guess it's correct.
Wait, but like, why is- Can the stamp be like that?
Can the stamp be curved?
Holy shit, an ID expires in like, that long?
20 years ID card?
That's crazy.
Wait, I should- You're right.
Okay, what's the number again?
6-4-3-1.
Hello, is she home?
Oh, she's not home.
Oh, she lives by herself, that's sad.
Margaret.
Do we have friends, Margaret?
Let me talk to you.
Everything looks good!
Um...
Wait, is this how you look like?
Yeah, you are, but like, I just wanted to fuck with you.
I mean, everything looks alright.
I feel like you look- You're okay, you know what?
You're one of the good ones.
Margaret Bubbles.
Yeah, I just don't know if this is- If it's okay if this is like, facing to like, that angle.
Like, nothing strange so far.
Alright.
Yeah, she's not a doppelganger.
We do not serve doppelganger kind here in this apartment.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yay!
Welcome home, Margaret!
Go back to your sad life living alone, I guess.
I say as I also live alone.
Guys, I'm not sad!
I'm not sad!
Oh, is it 32?
I see.
Oh, it's 42.
It's been a long time since I've watched Hitchhiker's Guide of the Galaxy.
42.
I was like, it's something 2.
I was almost there.
I'm not sad!
I have a dog.
What?
It's not 42?
No!
Science has been wrong?
Is this shirt supposed to be striped?
I mean, you look the same.
What's your ID card, woman?
There you go, thank you.
Sorry, sorry, I got a little too aggressive there.
I was sad that I got the answer wrong.
Oh, he asked for the year.
Why the fuck is it 1942?
I mean, it could be the year 42.
Illinois...
Sorry, I got a little antsy there.
I got the answer wrong and it made me sad.
Oh wait, that's 3.
Wait, is it supposed to be 3 or 4?
Oh, it's supposed to be 3.
Okay, you live on...
Floor 1, 4th floor.
Illinois...
8...
845323014 Wait, why is there 2 of you?
Wait, are you twins?
I was like, oh this is the right mall.
Oh wait, what's your mall?
Okay, that's your mall.
Oh my god, it's twins.
Okay.
What's your phone number?
6996...
6...
9...
6.
Oh my god, they're twins.
Someone would say quadruplets.
This is... what do you need?
Where's your roommate?
No, there are no important documents in the... okay.
She seems normal.
Nice.
Why did they say quadruplets?
Oh, he's...
Like, it's unknown where is an innocent boy.
Oh, silly chatter.
Wait, but like...
I guess it doesn't look at colors of the shirt.
I guess everything looks good.
Yeah, they're all on there.
Alright, get in there.
Get in there.
Be with your sister.
You seem pretty, Norma.
Yay, I did it!
Hello.
Where's your ID card?
Oh wait, sorry.
Wrong one.
Identification card, please.
Alright.
Is that your ID?
Okay.
Yeah, there's nothing wrong.
Oh my god, Afton!
Oh my god, William Afton?
From the byte?
Of 95?
Of 42?
Sorry, the byte of 42?
Alright, DDD, the triple D's.
Oh my god.
The byte of 42.
He was like, Dr. W.
Afton.
Oh shit, fuck.
There's too many documents.
Where is this?
Oh wait, there's your ID card.
250-489-656.
Okay, that seems correct.
You look like him.
What's your phone number?
1425.
Hello?
Is your wife home?
This is Maya, what do you need?
Where's your roommate?
Okay, so William Afton is actually outside.
Alright, everything looks good.
301.
Yeah, 301.
Wait, they're not even married.
They're just roommates.
Guys, look.
She didn't take...unless she wants to be a strong, independent woman in 1955.
She didn't take his last name.
Oh my god.
And they're just roommates.
Oh, it could be their fianc, you're right.
They were roommates.
Oh yeah, they're just roommates.
Everything looks good.
Nothing suspicious out there until he starts murdering children.
Alright.
Yep, yep, yep.
Yep.
Wait, there's lore in this update?
You're safe to go, sir.
You're right in.
Well done.
I think I'm doing a great- Oh!
He wanted?
The fuck does that mean?
Okay.
Let me double check to be sure.
Let me-
Just to be sure.
You know...
She might have had a really rough day at the-
She might have had a really rough day- You don't know her life, guys.
She might have had a really rough day at the seamstress store.
You don't know her life.
Okay.
F to Margaret Bubbles.
Look, this- Look, the Doppelganger worked really hard on these fake IDs.
Okay?
Fake IDs are very expensive, guys.
Like, I might as well entertain it for a little bit.
Just to make her feel better.
Just- Just saying.
Someone's like, we already let her in, ducky.
Not hard enough on plastic surgery.
Look, she ran out of money.
Just to be safe.
Let's call her.
She might have gotten into a really fucked up accident.
And Margaret could use a roommate.
Right now, I'm the only one in the apart- You live alone.
You're always the only one in the apartment.
I'm sorry, ma'am.
I called the apartment.
And like, Margaret is already living there.
So I have to- I have to press the button.
She just had an allergic reaction.
Alright.
You may continue with your work.
Don't get so cruel.
Wait, you're back?
Wait, did you go outside again?
Did you?
Okay, let me just- Make sure you didn't go outside while I was busy with this.
1425.
Wait a minute.
You were just here.
Did you forget something at the physics office?
Was there a child you forgot to kill?
Oh shit.
All the people?
You mean your roommate?
Slash husband?
Alright, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, but he's already- I mean, you- Great job, though.
Very good job.
It's- It's a lot.
It's definitely- You definitely worked really hard on this identity.
Guys, I feel like- There must be like- A guy that just makes fake IDs for all these doppelgangers.
And he must be really fucking rich.
Or she.
I wish I was that person.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Just a bit late.
Probably.
Seems like a very- But what if he's the real one?
There can only be one William Afton!
Alright.
Did I do it?
Did I do my job correctly?
Yay!
I got you too!
I got three!
Sorry, I can't count.
I didn't eliminate any neighbors!
Let's go!
See?
None of my neighbors died!
Look at that!
It's that easy.
Alright.
What's the news today?
Hello, sir.
Meet Henry, the doormat of the month.
Courtesy- What did he and Henry do?
I captured three!
How many did Henry capture?
Good news.
There's no missing persons report.
You guys don't think I'm crazy, right?
Good afternoon.
Are you on the list?
Raftalin.
Alright.
Kapuchin.
You're on the list.
Everything seems alright.
The triple D's.
I am a rising- Wait.
Yeah, everything looks alright.
For your entire complexion.
Okay, not this one.
Alright, where's my data?
Uh, Raftalin.
Uh, where do you live?
F-O-3-O-4?
The fourth floor?
Raftalin.
Kapuchin.
I mean, that's spelled correctly.
You're a housewife.
Why did you go outside?
It doesn't say why.
It just says you live here.
Huh.
Why won't you tell me why you went outside, ma'am?
Huh?
4-2-8-5.
Let's see what your husband thinks about this.
Going outside.
A housewife says house.
Wait, why did it hang up?
Did I call the wrong number?
4-2-5-8.
I did.
Hello, this is Al speaking.
Where's your roommate?
Okay, so she is...
Okay, so she is out.
Okay.
She is out.
I mean, everything looks good.
People need a touch crash.
No, they don't.
I mean...
This is too perfect.
Okay, I'll question her.
Why did you go outside?
There's nothing wrong.
She's right.
She's got me there.
You know she's the wife of a lawyer.
Alright.
I guess I'll let you win.
Everything looks good.
You're also on today's list.
Oh my god, the milkman's coming home.
Ooh.
We're gonna see the milkman tonight.
Alright.
Go in there and have fun with your husband.
Hello.
Yeah.
I mean, your face looks like your face.
Wait, where's your entry request?
Thank you.
Alright, Isaac.
Wait, the stamp's wrong.
Or, oh wait, no, it's smudge.
That counts, right?
It smudged a bit.
Okay, where do you live?
Let me dox you real quick.
F0202.
Okay, lives alone.
Isaac.
Guys.
Alright.
F0202.
Guys, just cause he looks like a reporter doesn't mean he's evil.
Guys.
Everything is fake news, guys.
Isaac, guys.
I mean, nothing seems wrong.
7332.
Alright.
No one picks up.
I mean, everything looks good, sir.
I have nothing else to report about you.
Can I also have an autograph for my nephew?
He loves watching the Channel 5 News.
Also, if you know the weather girl, I'd like to have her autograph too.
Alright, everything looks good, Mr. Isaac.
Guys.
I don't think anything suspicious is going around, so...
Yeah, come right in.
Alright.
Go back to your sad little apartment.
Oh my god, it's the Milkman!
The star of the show, right here.
It's him.
Alright.
Woah, Milkman.
Francis Moses.
I am coming home from my job as the Milkman.
Everything looks great, Mr. Francis.
F0302.
Yep, that's exactly the myth himself.
Oh my god, the man, the myth, the legend.
Okay, F0302.
And he lives alone?
Ladies, he's single.
For all you housewives out there.
Alright.
For...
Guys, and I have his phone number.
Housewives, housewives.
I...
Oh, okay.
Wait, alright.
Wait, everything looks good, Mr. Francis.
Alright, let me check his ID, just to be sure.
235569418.
Francis Moses.
Alright.
You're good to go, sir.
Let me double check.
Just in case.
Yep, you look very depressed.
That sounds about right.
Maybe he's tired from all the housewives.
You know?
It's like that Mr. Fantastic meme.
Maybe...
Maybe he's just tired.
What's wrong with the hat?
Take off your hat.
Ask him about the hat.
Milkman, take off your hat.
Entertain us, chat.
Guys, he's a person.
We can't just ask him to take off his hat, guys.
We can't.
He has an actual, reputable job.
Rodrigo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The child support must be crazy.
Guys!
We can't just randomly ask people to take off their hats.
No, the hat stays on.
Alright, you're good to go, Mr. Milkman.
Yes, we can.
It's literally our job.
Alright.
Go in.
Mr. Hatman.
Perfect.
Wait, I don't like how you said that.
Wait.
Wait, did I fuck up?
I don't like how you...
Wait.
Why did he say it like that?
Wait a minute.
Why did the Hatman say it like that, guys?
I don't know.
Perfect.
I think we all got distracted.
But if he was a doppelganger, we all maybe got a little too distracted.
Every night, all around the world, 100 people see this cloud in their dreams.
If this cloud appears in your dream, do not forget it is a dream.
Okay.
Thanks, Cloudman.
The Church of Cloud.
Wait, you're the other sister.
You're not.
You're the other one.
The one with the mole on the left.
Yeah, her.
Selene.
The earrings.
Yeah, they're square.
Sir...
Severed...
Check.
Approved.
Yeah, the triple three.
Triple D's look about right.
Where does she live again?
First, fourth floor.
Severed...
Wait, are they all just neighbors?
Did the doppelgangers just give up?
I'm just too good at my job.
What can I say?
7, 8, 5, 6, 1, 3...
2, 6, 9.
I'm just that good at my job.
Alright.
Nothing seems...
Nothing seems wrong.
6, 9, 9, 6, 6...
9...
6.
Hello?
Is your twin home?
Illinois.
Where's your roommate?
Okay, so she is outside.
Alright.
Nice.
Wait, let me double check.
I mean, everything looks good.
Her most to the left.
She has the square earrings.
Her little hair twirl right there.
Alright, 1, 2, 3...
1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3.
1, 2, 3, yeah.
Alright.
Get to your other twin.
What about the lips?
It could be natural, guys.
Don't judge.
It could all be natural.
Are you a dog?
Are you on the list?
You're not on the list.
Because I had to leave due to an emergency.
You're a child!
What emergency can you have?
F204.
Left eye green, right eye blue.
Where's your...
Where's your guardian?
Give me your ID.
Wow.
Hey there, don't be rude to me today.
I am the doorman.
Because I get paid minimum wage, I am fucking high with power.
This is the only time I can use my authority.
Because my life fucking sucks because I work as a doorman.
Alright.
Let's see.
Anastasia.
Whose lost child is this?
Okay.
That seems correct.
1-3-2-6-9-8-5-3-4.
I shouldn't even let her in the apartment.
She doesn't even have the right papers.
I mean, everything looks correct.
She just sleeps outside until she gets her...
Until she files a proper request to go out.
1-3-4-6.
Hello.
This is Nacha speaking.
Where's your roommate?
Do you also call your daughter, your children, your roommates?
She doesn't even pay rent.
I don't believe that her daughter even pays rent.
Hit the button and make her regret it.
No.
She is not on today's list.
Do I just not let her in?
Don't assume.
How does she pay rent?
I mean, she could have a part-time job.
That's pretty fucked if you let your sister pay...
make your sister pay for rent while she's going to middle school.
Um...
Uh... I mean, everything looks correct.
I don't see anything else.
Alright.
Wait.
I actually didn't check your face.
Sorry.
I was not paying attention to your face.
You were so rude to me that I wasn't caring about it.
Okay, yeah.
Everything looks good.
Alright.
I guess you can go through.
I mean, she kills the mom and... whoops.
Wait, what?
I just let you through.
Why are you back here?
I'm just gonna call them real quick.
What floor did they live?
I think it's the third floor, right?
Oh, it's the first floor.
Okay.
6996.
6...
9...
Wait, how did you get... why did you get back downstairs?
I just caught...
I just let you in.
What if they're triplets?
Maybe they're triplets.
Where's your roommate?
Okay, yeah.
I was gonna say.
Alright.
Sorry.
Let me...
How would you know if you're on the list?
Huh, ma'am?
How would you know?
Is it me or does the Bugmasters simulator look like Mark Grayson?
Am I not going crazy?
Or a very, very tired Mark Grayson?
Alright, get outta here!
That's right.
We don't need no triplets here in my apartment.
Nice.
That was easy.
Wait, this is an easy game.
Or maybe I'm just really good.
Could be both.
Whoa.
Wait, who are you?
Wait, where the fuck do you live?
Wait, how come...
Wait, okay.
McZooey Rodboys.
Oh my god.
He's the Rodman.
He's here to finish Milkman's job.
Okay, third floor.
Third.
McZooey Rodboys.
964 964 516184 Retired.
What did you mean by that?
The triple D's.
Nothing seems suspicious about you, sir.
Yeah.
Him and the Rodboys.
Why aren't you on the list, though?
Why are there so many emergencies?
What's going on in this city?
Okay, let's see.
4242 Wait, is he not the Rodboy?
Who's your roommate?
Oh, okay.
They're all here anyway.
Wait.
Oh my god.
It's the Rodboys?
Oh my...
You know what?
I think... I feel like you should be up there instead of him.
I...
Honestly, I wish his name was the...
You should be the one to live that life.
God, the Rod.
He is an actual improvement.
Not gonna lie.
Alright, get out of here.
Rod over Rod.
Rodboy sounds better.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
The Rodboys.
The King or Rod versus Rod.
In what year was the ultimate answer to life in everything published?
Wait.
1942?
What would it be, guys?
I don't understand.
It was not for...
Wait, what?
But it's not 1979.
Is he from the future?
Oh, he is.
Look, he has...
He's a hippie.
There's no hippies in 1955.
What the fuck happened?
Wait, what?
There's a book?
Why is it 1979?
There was no hippies in 1955.
What book was it?
What the...
Oh, it's a Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy.
Some good shit.
Oh, it's a Hitchhiker's Guide to the...
Oh, the Hitchhiker's Guide was published that time.
Oh, I didn't know that.
See you tomorrow.
Okay.
Yeah, look.
She didn't even give me any documentations.
Like, she was not trying anymore.
Like...
If she...
If she gave...
If she gave me an ID or like papers, that's not discrimination if she never even tried.
She gave up on entrance.
She literally gave up.
She gave me no papers.
Alright.
Yeah!
I did it!
That's pretty... That's so easy.
Open detailed information.
I didn't... See, look at that.
Wait, double games have entered?
Wait, but I captured... Oh, that have entered.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
I did it.
Alright, continue.
Woah.
What?
Where am I?
Here are the rules.
Where the fuck am I?
Players take turns using one of their cards.
You can only use a card equal or high.
I can't believe my Oshi is people with dangling eyeballs.
Actual demo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
J is... Oh my god.
Is this...
Is this math?
What?
You can only use a card equal or higher than the one on the table or a card of the same symbol regardless of value.
J is worth 11, Q is worth 12, K is worth 13 and Aces are worth 1 and 14 when there is a K.
What?
Oh, and 14 when there is a K.
Oh, okay.
The first to use all their cards wins the round.
Oh, equal or higher.
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
I figured it out.
Very well.
Time to play.
You start this round.
I forgot what the points were.
Wait.
Isn't queen higher?
Oh, symbol.
I did it.
Okay.
I'm doing it.
Okay, I got a card.
Grab a card.
Yay!
I won!
Wait, what?
Wait.
But I won.
I won.
That's a 3.
That's cheating.
Maybe he won't have it.
Yay!
I did it!
I'm so good at cards.
Only one day we will meet again.
Goodbye.
Look at that.
I might not have good gacha rules, but at least I'm good at cards.
Mine.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
So easy.
Alright, Wednesday.
February 9th.
Preferred party leader.
Mr. Kepler will receive an award for founding the triple D's and his great work.
A pair of spies have discovered an allied territory.
Wait, is this World War 2?
Although the enemy government claims to have no knowledge of this event and possibly...
Wait, no.
It's after World War 2.
I'm sorry, I got my ears off.
I saw allied territory.
Sorry, it's the Cold War.
Sorry, there's a lot of wars.
I'm thinking about the Cold War.
So while we're dealing with doppelgangers, they're dealing with the paper police shit right now.
Oh.
They have their own paper police.
But here in America, we have to deal with them.
I feel like they got the better end of the deal.
Because like...
Theirs is more about political stuff.
Ours is that we're getting slaughtered by people that look like us.
And that's a lot more scarier.
I feel like the other side is having a better time than us in regards to what's going on right now.
Doppelgangers is a lot more worse.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
Would you...
I'd rather not be killed by someone that looks like someone I know.
Ours is a lot scarier.
Scarier.
Alright.
That's cool.
No, Aunt Nora.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Did you go to the Willy Wonka chocolate factory?
Did you...
Oh my god.
What's wrong?
My face is the face of an average human.
Alright, Lois.
I'll entertain you for a little bit.
You know what?
Lois the Liz.
Why she...
She went to the chocolate factory, okay?
Alright, she got the golden ticket.
8, 9, 4, 5, 6, 9, 7, Oh man, Lois.
Everything looks so good.
Oh man.
You worked so hard.
It really is a shame that...
Oh man.
Just call.
Just entertain her.
You're right.
I'll entertain her and call the phone too.
She forgot her makeup today.
If only you weren't earful.
Alright, where's your roommate?
Aw, and she wasn't home?
Aw, Lois.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't be rude, Doki.
She forgot her facial care today.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank god.
Aw, Lois.
Now I just feel sad.
You worked so hard.
You had everything perfect, ma 'am.
Like, just...
Aw, just one little detail.
Just one tiny detail.
Doki, she just ate too many blueberries.
I'm sorry, ma'am.
I'm sorry.
Alright, don't discriminate.
She is beautiful.
Alright.
Oh!
Okay.
Maybe one too many hole.
Sorry, I had to cover her face a little bit.
Guys!
Guys, look.
I didn't cover her face because I thought she was ugly, okay?
I was just checking my list, guys.
Look, see?
I didn't cover her face this time.
Alright, Gloria Schmidt.
Okay.
Two eyelashes.
There's her...
There's that.
I'm a resident of 04-1974.
The three, the triple D's.
Yellow.
I think...
I mean, it's fine.
Some people...
Some people have yellow eyes.
Oh my god, you're calling me fucking racist.
What's wrong with yellow eyes?
She could be wearing contacts, guys.
5-1-2-3.
5-1...
Is yellow eyes the deal breaker?
She has yellow eyes.
She's a demon.
Alright, is your wife at home?
Alright, there you go.
Not all yellow eye people are demons, guys.
4-0-2.
Okay.
Where's her ID?
Where did I put her ID?
Okay, there it is.
Uh...
Her age?
It doesn't even tell me what her age was.
Uh...
6-9-8-5-2-2-3-4-1.
Alright.
Alright, all of them seems fine.
You're good to go, ma'am.
And you're on the list too, Gloria.
Wait, is her name actually Gloria?
Wouldn't it be funny if her name was never Gloria?
Alright.
Go right in.
Alright, child.
Where's your entry request?
Alright, let me call your mom.
1-3-4-6.
1-3-4...
How could you let your child go outside without her documentation, ma'am?
Alright.
Well...
Alright, they forgot their entry.
Okay.
Well, your mom backed you up.
So all I have is this.
Anastacia Michaelis.
1-3-2-6-9-8-5-3-4- Triple D's.
Hmm...
The fact that you don't have your documentation...
I don't know.
I feel like...
I feel like because you don't have it, then why should I let you in?
I mean, can I just tell her to get her documentation?
The mom alibi is 100%.
Just because the mom is hot, you can't just believe everything she says, guys.
Guys...
We don't have any other information!
Really, all I have is
her...
Seems that everything is perfect with my appearance.
Alright.
Um...
Women never lie.
Okay.
Alright.
She doesn't have it.
Like, can I just... Can I send her away if she doesn't have it?
Hmm...
I don't know.
Am I allowed...
Do I say no?
Oh no, that's her expiration date.
That's the ID expiration date.
Guys, that's not her birth date.
That's like whenever her ID fucking expires.
Ken.
Come here.
Tell your mom to come downstairs.
I'll wait for her.
Why can't I just call her mom?
Like...
Be like...
Tell your mom to come downstairs.
And fucking...
Bring your entry date.
Why do I have to... Oh my god.
I did call her.
She was just like... Yeah, I forgot to give her the...
She was just like...
I forgot to give her her entry.
And then...
That was it.
I was like, okay.
Are you not coming down?
I guess not.
Oh my god.
I guess I have to send you...
Alright, if she kills the mom, it's not my fault.
It's not my fault.
It's the mom's fault for not coming downstairs to give me her fucking...
Wait.
Whoa.
The zen pic went hard, I guess.
I mean, like...
The shape of my head?
What's so strange about it?
It has a nice shape.
I mean...
Wow.
Miss Potato.
I mean, it is.
She is Miss Potato's shape.
Alright.
I'm sorry.
I don't think you were able to, like, fix the head of your shape in, like, ten minutes, ma'am.
Thank you.
I'm great at my job.
Oh shit!
What if I just let him through?
Wait, she took off his hat for us!
Oh my god, do you think he likes us?
He's off, guys.
He's off the clock.
Oh, you're right.
He's off.
What if I just let him through looking at anything?
Tempted.
You know what?
I don't need to check anything.
Go right through.
Why would you ask him anything?
You don't need any checks here.
Bring him in.
What is the number of different permutations of the most relevant The fuck does that mean?!
Okay.
Google chat.
42.
Yes.
Wait, why is it 17?
42.
Nice.
Wait, is it actually 42?
Wait, is that why the answer to life is 42?
It's at least two.
Guys, now I don't know.
No.
I can't believe.
It's boob.
You can google.
Guys, why google if I have you guys here?
I will put this as an answer if you don't tell me the real answer.
Why are you asking us?
Oh, true.
You're right, we're missing a number.
We are in chat GPT.
That's why there's chat in chat GPT, guys.
Chat GPT.
What is the number of different permutations of the most relevant Mersenne prime in computing?
I feel like I am a fucking child.
I am a child.
Guys, if you laugh at this, you're just as immature as me.
You're just as immature.
You are perfect.
I wouldn't have it any other way.
Alright, guys.
What's the actual number, guys?
Is it 300?
I don't even know.
What the fuck is 302?
302 40.
The fuck does that... I don't even...
What does that even mean?
Thank you, chat GPT.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I think I fucked up.
Wait.
Guys, I think...
Oh, shit.
Guys, I think I left...
Guys, I think I fucked up.
I think... Oh, shit.
Maybe this isn't the real one.
Guys, it might not be the real one.
Guys, he took off his hat.
Okay?
He took off his hat.
Let them in.
Turkey just left both of them.
You know what's better than one milkman?
Two milkman.
4122.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
That's the fake milkman?
Oh, shit.
Did I got the right one?
I got the right one.
Oh, fuck.
Wait.
It looks the same.
He's our milkman.
Milkman?
Never punish, guys.
Never.
Numbers?
They're the same numbers.
Look.
235... Oh.
Sorry.
I mean, they're not the same.
They're not the same, guys.
Okay.
Alright.
Never punish.
Let's go.
No.
Let him in, too.
Turkey.
Let him in.
Hey.
Nice.
He did it.
I can count.
Let's go.
Louis.
Oh, is this a real Louis?
I mean, you have this.
You have the bow.
You have the circular.
What does it matter?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6... There's no way that shit... There's no way that's gonna fuck with me.
Alright, where's everything?
Alright, at least we have this.
Okay, this is...
Floor 1.
Okay.
Louis Dolinsky.
Uh... Floor 1.
Alright, let me talk to your husband real quick.
I said, what the fuck you're doing?
Bro, she... Guys, she remembered her makeup this time.
She came back.
Guys, she came back to put on makeup.
1, 1, 5, 2.
Alright.
Is your roommate here?
Is your wife, your roommate here?
That's not your... Oh, wait.
I forgot to ask him about her ID card.
1, 1, 5, 2.
Sorry, I gotta call back about the ID.
Hello?
Roman?
Okay.
Can you come downstairs to give it to her?
No?
Alright.
Fuck me, I guess.
I definitely don't get paid enough for it.
Alright.
I mean, it seems like everything looks good to go.
Can I talk about your appearance?
You're not purple.
I mean, you're not purple though, so are you really perfect?
Nope.
Yep, yep, yep.
Alright.
Go right in.
I believe she's real.
Wait, what?
Wait, why is it A?
I did everything perfectly.
Oh!
But like, she never gave me her ID!
She doesn't even give me her ID!
What do I check?
Do I just say yes?
No, it says like...
Oh, is it just right?
Do I just say right?
Oh yeah, I didn't care.
Oh, I put...
I put yes.
There's a person...
He's on my list though.
It...
It's not fair!
He was on my personal list.
I should get out.
He's on our list, guys.
He was on our list.
I didn't care.
It might have been the true...
Okay.
The people...
Yeah, he is the people's milkman.
Chat.
Alright.
What's today's news?
I see her husband has been acting suspiciously.
Suspiciously.
Coming home late.
Not giving her the same attention as before.
And always having important...
Work...
Ah, yes.
Important work meeting with the milkman.
He is a menace to society.
Taking away our husbands and wives.
My husband wasn't like this.
Says the woman.
My god.
He's taking our husbands and our wives?
Won't anybody stop him?
Stop the milkman.
Important meetings.
Oh, he's back.
Good afternoon.
Hello there.
Alright, Lois.
I mean, everything else looks correct.
There's our mom.
I mean, I looked at your information.
Oh, you remember your ID this time.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Milk.
89456973 Uh...
Oh, wait.
Nevermind.
Get out.
Get out, Lois.
Yeah, you thought because I can't read, I wouldn't catch that?
That's fucking right.
Get out of here!
Oh, she's the other twin.
Illinois.
33...
mole to the right, triangle.
Everything looks right.
Oh, wait, where's your ID?
Okay, well, let's see what your fucking twin says.
Wait, where does she live again?
I'm not remembering where people live.
Floor, fourth floor.
Uh...
6996...
6...9...
9...
6...
What do you mean, earrings?
It's a triangle.
Wait.
What's wrong with earrings?
It looks the same.
See?
Triangles.
Illinois always has triangle earrings, guys.
Look at it.
Look, see?
You're talking about the other.
You're talking about her other sister, guys.
Her other sister is the square.
Oh, I forgot.
Sorry.
It's because I wanted to call her again.
Maybe if I call her enough, she'll give me her number.
That I already have.
Okay, what happened to your sister's documents?
Okay, it is in the apartment.
Yep, I want her to...
I want her consensually to give her number to me.
Not because I have her number because of my job.
Alright, let's see.
I mean, like, everything looks correct.
I don't know if anything else looks wrong.
I just don't have her ID.
Yeah, I just don't have her ID.
There's nothing else that's wrong.
Alright, go in.
It's not reverse.
Oh my god, now you're fucking with me.
Now you're fucking...
That's her twin, guys!
That's her twin!
She's...
Guys, this is why me and Illinois...
That's why she'll pick me over you guys.
I can tell the difference between the twins.
You can't.
You're looking for a real partner.
And I know the difference.
Alright, you can go in.
I mean, I don't...
I don't have your ID card.
Do I pick yes?
I guess yes, right?
You're on the list, yeah.
You are, okay.
Yeah, go right in.
Perfect.
Oh my god.
I'm like...
Did you even try?
Why did you come back?
I trusted you again?
Ma'am, if it doesn't work the first time...
Why would it work a second time?
Surely it won't work this time.
Maybe they have a different doorman.
She should've went...
I'm sorry, I had to add shift, guys.
Why did you go to a different shift?
The fuck?
Oh, is it the whole alphabet equals numbers shit?
Guys, alright.
Any math prodigies in my chat?
Is it 42?
At least she's...
No, she didn't even try at all.
Guys, what's the numbers?
40, just look up the...
Just look up the wiki.
42069 42069
42069 42069 Okay, sorry.
You're so silly.
Guys, okay.
ChatGPT, what is M-V-W-K-Z-I-E-X-N plus W-F-L-T-E-N-X
Alright, thank you, ChatGPT.
Thank you.
Oh my god, I love streaming.
Alright.
Good afternoon.
Hello, sir.
Mr. Red Boys.
Have you ever thought about changing your name to Rod Boys, sir?
I think you'd like...
I think you'd enjoy it a lot more if you were called the Rod Boys.
3-3 Okay.
What clue?
9-6-4-5-1 6-1-8-4
I miss...
I miss Mr. Rod Boy.
I mean, everything looks good.
Let me call your son real quick.
4... I forgot the number.
4-2-4-2 4-2-4-2 I don't trust a man.
Yeah, but you trust a milkman.
How come you trust a milkman, huh?
I mean, everything seems correct.
Triple D's.
Triple... Is that D?
Triple D.
Except his name isn't Rod Boy.
Alright, go right in, sir.
Wait, are you on the list?
Oh, you are.
Come right in, sir.
Everything looks good.
Don't worry.
I don't remember it.
I think... yeah.
It looks the same.
What's your ID?
Nice.
Alright.
Isaac Goss.
Look at that handsome man.
Alright.
Uh...
2-2 Isaac Goss.
4-5-6-9-8-5-5-1-2 Yeah.
Everything looks good.
Oh my god, I'm getting really good at this.
Now I just gotta call.
Just to be sure.
I know you're not lying to me.
But I just gotta be sure, you know?
Alright, nice.
Alright, go right in, sir.
Go right in.
Woah.
You're awfully happy today.
Where's your...
Why aren't you on the list?
There can't all be emergencies.
Why are they...
Why are all their excuses just emergencies?
Like...
What the fuck...
Did a fucking bank explode or something?
I didn't even get to handle...
Handle the money?
There can't all be emergencies, Margaret.
Two eyelashes.
Big smile.
Okay, where does Margaret live?
Second floor.
Third.
Margaret Bubbles.
1-0-3-2-6-8-0-1-4 6-4-3-1 I'm res'ing the building.
Triple D's.
Margaret.
Bubbles.
Yeah, seems fine.
6-4-3-1 6-4-3-1 Never trust anyone named Bubbles.
Not even Bubbles from the past?
Oh, nobody's home.
I guess you're free to come in.
Alright, go right in, Margaret.
Doesn't seem pretty...
Doesn't seem suspicious.
But you were just here.
Okay, wait, let me call just to be sure.
Didn't I let you in?
I'm pretty sure I let you in, right?
Oh, they're all blurring together.
I can't remember.
Wait, 1-1-5-2 1-1-5-2 What's that yesterday?
What was that yesterday?
They're all blurring together.
Wait, I did it?
Oh, I kicked out your impostor!
I'm sorry, ma'am.
I'm sorry.
They're all blurring together.
8-9-4-5-6-9-7-2-3 Lois Stilinski Stilinski They're all blurring together, ma'am.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I mean, you look alright.
So you know what?
You're in.
The purple is orange.
And you're not purple too!
Look at that.
Good for you.
Come right in.
Oh, yeah.
I didn't ask about- It's fine.
I know she's not- It's fine.
Oh, shit!
My other eye is for better vision.
Okay.
He opened his third eye.
That checks out.
Yeah, that seems right.
I'm so good at this game.
Wait, this game is so easy.
Wait.
Aren't you with the husband?
Was I just talking to him?
Um...
Was I not just talking to him?
To a Mr. Roman- Mr. Stilinski?
Oh, okay.
Um...
Goodbye.
Guys.
These guys gotta check the schedule.
Mr. Roman Stilinski is already home.
I think on A, I fucked up one of them.
Yeah.
Which one was it?
Who the fuck was Ellen?
Oh!
Oh, and she doesn't have- Oh!
Whoops.
Yeah, I fucked up Margaret.
And, uh...
The model.
When does the game get harder?
Yeah, that's right.
I'm getting a little cocky.
Wait, let me see.
Let me see.
I think I want some appropriate music going on here.
Let me get some appropriate music here.
Let's see.
I'm just saying.
Okay.
Copyright free.
Hotel music.
Hotel, no copyright music.
Yeah, that's what I- Oh, hotel lobby music.
Alright, do I wanna- You know what?
Fuck it.
Guys, I'm gonna get copyright- Wait, actually royalty free music.
Hotel lobby music.
Copyright free.
Alright.
If I get a copyright strike, I swear to God.
Yeah, let's put this on repeat.
Fuck it.
YouTube on repeat.
I won't get immersed, guys.
I'm here to get immersed, guys.
Alright.
Let's see.
I need to make sure I don't accidentally- Alright.
Oh, no.
They're like, turn off your ad block.
I'll be like, okay.
What's the point?
Give me my hotel lobby music!
There you go.
Alright.
Now I can be fully immersed.
Fully immersed in my hotel lobby.
No, I'm looking at the- The area.
Area.
Alright.
The double- The triple D breaks the record for doppelgangers captured in a week.
War again?
The government announced that they already have a plan of action against the latest movements of enemy countries.
A new baby joins the growing numbers of fatherless children in their communities.
Something never seen before.
So far, no mother has decided to speak about it.
Oh my god.
The milkman's going- He's aiming for non-housewives now?
Won't somebody stop him?
He's after the non-housewives.
He is going out of control.
Can someone stop this man?
He strikes again.
Good afternoon.
I don't know, that's- Okay, Alf.
Oh, you're Cappuccini!
Where's your ID?
Okay, Cappuccini.
Cappuccin.
Cappuccino.
Can't keep getting away with this.
I know, right?
Fourth floor.
Okay, lawyer.
I mean, Cappuccin.
4258.
I mean, Triple D is correct.
Wait, he doesn't have the monocle?
Maybe he put it on for fun.
Okay, so her husband's- Oh shit, sorry, I need to call again.
4258.
Oh shit.
I mean, it looks like that.
I forgot to talk about his ID again.
4258.
Cappuccino.
Y'all, don't be fooled.
The real Doki never made it past the store.
I don't know what this is, but don't believe the not.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
I mean, everything looks good, Mr. Cappuccino.
No ID card.
Wait, do I say yes when he doesn't have it?
I forgot.
No, I say no.
And then, yes, you look like him.
He wears a monocle.
And yeah, you're on the list.
Alright, go right in.
And if you're not him, well, I guess...
I guess sucks to be the wife right now.
Swirl.
The eyes.
Yep, seems right.
Swirl.
I say guys.
At this point, I'm gonna remember the fucking 2-2.
I'm gonna remember his, like...
All I need to do is remember his ID number.
456985512.
Let's do a speedrun.
7-3-3-2.
Alright.
It's Superman.
Superman is coming back from the Daily Planet.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, seems right.
Nothing suspicious here.
Oh, wait.
Where the triple D at?
Sir.
Oh, you don't see any problem with your application request?
You think you can get in here with a fake entry request?
Get out of here.
I don't know if you're a natural doppelganger, but like, if we accidentally killed an innocent person, then that's...
Imagine if it was just the reporter couldn't find his entry request, and then he got it forged and everything.
Um...
Goodbye, Superman.
That's right.
I'm gonna finish his job.
I'm gonna finish Lex Luthor's job.
Imagine if he wasn't even, like, a doppelganger.
He just fucking forged his entry request.
The printer just ran...
The printer just ran out of ink.
God.
Alright.
Well, you're not in the list.
Because I allude to a work...
How many work emerges... Okay, Mr. William Afton, if that is your real name.
Okay.
William Afton.
Okay, one, one.
Wait, no.
One, three.
Two, five.
Okay, yeah.
Goodbye.
Yeah.
That's right.
Only one man can kill children.
We don't need two children killers.
He always comes back.
A work emergency.
He killed another kid.
He's waiting every night.
Hello.
Oh, yay.
The other sister.
The hotter one.
Okay, three, three.
Alright, everything in the picture seems alright.
She's the hotter sister.
Okay, let's see.
What is it for?
First floor.
And then E, S, V, R, C, H, Z, T.
Where's your ID?
Okay.
7, 8, 5, 6, 1, 3, 6, 9.
Okay, 6, 9, 9, 6.
6, 9, 9, 6.
Hello, ma'am.
Can I talk to the hotter sister, please?
Where's your roommate?
Okay.
Alright.
That seems good for me.
Go right in.
Nice.
Why is she the hotter one?
The secret is that you always tell the other twin that she's the hotter one of the...
She's the hottest of the twins.
That's my secret.
You always tell one of the twins that they're the hotter one.
That's funny.
Alright.
Robertski.
Okay.
Triple D, triple D.
That's evil.
How many twins do you meet?
I've never tested it in theory yet.
Look, it's a theory, guys.
I've never tested it out.
Peachman.
Floor 1, 2.
Oh, he's a shoemaker.
Any twins in here to test this out?
1, 1, 4, 6, 5, 2, 2, 8, 9.
2, 6, 6, 8.
Stop.
Step 1.
I need to find some twins to test this theory out.
I mean, you guys can test it out for me, right?
Okay.
That was a dad, right?
Oh, Robertski.
Okay, Robertski, Peachman.
I mean, everything looks good.
Robertski.
Yep.
Wait, are you a shoemaker?
You are.
Go right in.
I'm zooming past this.
I shall beat Harry.
Or Henry.
Whoever his name was.
Oh, it was the blue green.
Oh my God, it's the mom.
Natcha.
Okay, Natcha.
Natcha Malachski.
Triple D, triple D.
1973.
204.
Left eye green.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
See, I know my left and right.
No, that was her right eye.
Left eye.
Left eye is this.
This is right.
Wait,
her...
Okay, if I detain her daughter, there won't be any orphans today.
If her daughter shows up, there won't be...
I'll just need her daughter to show up.
And then...
No one will know.
Okay.
There won't be any orphans if her daughter shows up.
I see gods.
Okay.
No witnesses.
1, 2, 3, 7, 3, 3, 2.
Guys, I might have went a little too fast.
Guys.
I got a little silly.
Okay.
I mean, it looks about right.
Nice, alright.
Getting right in.
Alright, now that I'm being a little silly, maybe we should turn the music off.
Haha.
The music made me a little too silly.
Wait, you were just here.
Wait.
Oh, is she dead?
Did I send in the wrong...
Okay, let's see if I sent in the right twin or not.
69966...
9...
6... Did I send in the wrong twin?
Alright, pick up.
Wait, the other twin was there.
Hahahaha.
Whoops.
Um...
But I know she's not... Oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, that's a little...
75613.
Oh, that's a little awkward.
When did I send in the wrong twin?
I mean, I guess you could go out there with...
Um...
Um... I'm just sending her...
Don't worry.
She's alive.
Hahahaha.
I can tell them apart.
They'll keep promising.
Wait, didn't I send you up there too?
Oh, wait.
Hahahaha.
Wait, did I also send you up there?
Wait.
2668.
Let me call real quick.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
He's alive.
Hahahaha.
Okay.
Okay, what I did...
Oh, they're alive.
Oh, it's the twin.
Oh, it's this.
It's the ball twins.
Ball chin.
Okay.
Get it.
I did something right.
Okay, thank god.
The testicle chin.
I got it.
Hey!
I think I did pretty well.
Wait a minute.
I don't remember.
Did I send you up there?
Hahahaha.
They're all blurring together, guys.
I don't remember.
Did I...
Did I send you up?
Roman...
Stilinski...
Okay, now I'm... Guys, I'm checking my list and checking it twice now.
Guys, I'm...
I'm making sure.
I might have messed up once, guys.
Just once.
4839405...
Did I send you up top already?
11521152.
Okay, there's Lois.
Okay, she's not...
Okay, so like...
This could be him.
Um...
It has to be him, right?
Yeah, public accountant.
You know what?
You're...
Let me make sure.
You seem alright.
You...
Oh yeah, what about his hat?
Oh my god.
It's crazy tonight and he's not wearing a hat one day.
Who would do that?
I mean, his ID doesn't have a hat.
Like...
When did he ever have a hat?
I'm not...
Alright.
It's fine.
Go right in.
He's just...
Look, he's been through a lot.
He's a public accountant.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I mean, we do need a mom.
Guys, we do need a mom for the child.
Let's just call the child real quick.
1-3-4-6 1-3-4 I don't know...
We do...
We do need a mom.
Oh, she's the only one in her apartment.
I quit.
Look, I kept messing up the eyes so she took the eyes out.
Do not send the...
She needs a mom!
Fine!
You're the one that wanted to make her an orphan, not me.
I was willing to fix the problem.
I was willing to fix the problem, chat.
Wait.
We're back.
Oh, wait.
Okay, okay, okay.
I didn't send the wrong one.
I didn't send...
His name was Romar.
Okay, I got that one right.
That's okay, guys.
I didn't fuck up.
I got that one correctly.
How many elements are in the power set of the...
The fuck?
ChatGPT!
ChatGPT.
I need help.
How many...
It cannot all...
Guys, 42 is not always the answer, chat.
It was like...
I don't know.
It was like boobies or something.
It cannot all be 42, guys.
Yes, it is.
It's the answer to everything.
Guys, I need to know how many elements are in the power set of the set of a happy palindromic numbers less than 10,000.
Okay.
4,180.
I swear to...
Okay, there's multiple people writing that, so it has to be true.
Oh.
Sorry, it was one guy that spammed it three times.
I'm timing you up.
Okay, I'm giving you a time out.
It was one guy that spammed it three times.
I was like, oh, okay.
I mean, that seems like a random number.
It was one guy that fucking posted it three times back to back.
Actually, one guy.
I was like, that seems like a random number.
And multiple people were posting it.
But it was not multiple people, it was red boys.
Fuck, I was setting him up.
Bro, why are you a double gang?
You're so cool.
Oh my god, the red boys.
Let's fucking go.
Oh my god.
You know he's cooler.
Is he?
It says gamer tag.
God damn it.
And he's the cooler red boy too.
Bro is way cooler.
Red boys, rise up.
Red boys, xx.
Alright.
I did pretty well today.
Oh man.
Neighbors eliminated by a double gang.
Wait, I got an A!
I passed!
Let's go!
Yippee!
Oh, different eyebrows?
What the fuck?
Illinois, not shit.
Oh yeah, cause I sent the real neighbor up top too.
It was nuts.
Oh yeah, I killed the mom, and then I sent the real twin up so she got double eliminated.
Whoops.
That's my bad.
Killed.
Yay!
I passed though, guys.
I passed.
I got two and I still I got an A!
Okay, clearly they were not that important.
Oh man, I knew there was a double ganger and I still sent her up there.
Truly, I think I quite, guys, I think I could be Employee of the Month, guys.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When does the game get hard, bro?
Thank you for the super chat.
Guys, all I'm saying is that neighbor, that means there's a free apartment room and in this economy, guys, come on, the rent is great.
Great rent, great doorsman, by the way.
Like, you get to have the apartment building rent by me as the doorsman and I will keep you all safe.
I will keep you all safe.
How much is rent?
Um, enough.
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How are you scoring with the twins now?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And we have the milkman.
Like, come on.
What more would you want, chat?
Will you have a doorsman job?
I don't think I wanna live there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All I'm saying...
I got an A, guys.
You can't judge me.
I got an A!
They said I did a great job.
You're not the ones that marked my papers.
Alright.
I think... Do we do one more run or do we call it here, chat?
What are the other...
Wait, actually, what are the other game modes?
Oh, there's the clown.
True experience of a workman.
How many runs are there?
Challenge the clown to one more?
One more?
Alright.
Really needs that death confession move now after this.
Alright, we'll do one more run.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm average.
Look at that.
Oh, wait.
Did I got fired?
Wait.
I got...
Oh,
I finished the way.
I was gonna be like...
Wait, did I just got fired?
I didn't click continue.
Oh, wait.
I won.
Oh, yay.
I won these.
What is this?
Nightmare mode.
Holy shit.
It has eyes.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, right here must be really cheap.
Wait, but who kills...
Did they just kill...
What?
Is that springtrap?
Or is this...
Peter?
Oh my gosh, what the fuck?
You're so fucked up looking already.
How do I know?
Oh my god.
What about milkman?
Is that the milkman?
What did they do to you?
Oh no, what did they do to you?
Oh my god, the milkman was a freak all along.
Oh no.
The milkman was a freak.
Okay, floor third...
Wait, third floor, first floor.
6-3-2-5 2-5-9-8-4 Oh, he's a skin carpenter.
The milk freak.
Look, even monsters have to be worried, okay?
Where does he live?
5-2-4-1 5-2- 4-1
God, I need to get lost.
Oh, wait.
There's nobody home.
Um...
I mean, you look okay.
Can't tell.
I mean, I...
You all look like freaks!
I...
I'm sorry!
It's really difficult!
I like the milkman better this way.
Okay.
Behold my presence, human.
Alright.
Open your entry.
Whoa.
Wait, you're not on the list.
I suddenly summoned into the mortal world.
Oh yeah, shit.
Don't you hate it when that happens?
When those stupid humans just summon you for like some deal or some shit?
Yeah.
That's rough, buddy.
2-4-5-2 No, wait!
Wait, no, it's 4.
Sorry, I can't...
Oh my god, there's too many dots.
Oh, this is nightmare mode.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Yeah, sounds like an appropriate emergency.
Ex-lanithro.
Okay.
2-5-3 2-5-9-6-8 Alright, everything looks good.
Yeah, he has sharp teeth.
Look.
Oh, look at that.
The teeth are sharp.
Alright.
Everything looks good, buddy.
Go straight in.
Oh, shit.
I forgot to call.
Okay, let's...
8-6-6-2 Let's see if they're alive.
Oh, okay.
Guys, he picked up.
Look at that.
Look at that, guys.
Guys, he picked up.
We're safe.
Okay, we're okay.
Oh, is this the...
Oh, shit.
That's the...guys.
Wait, that's the other twin.
That's one of the twins.
Uh...
Yangluowangdu 3-1 No, that's not the twin.
That's a different person.
Oh, that's someone's wife.
How the fuck did this guy escort her?
Damn.
He must have a...
He must be really funny.
7-9...
Oh.
Oh, I'm sorry, ma'am.
I know you're...
I'm sorry.
I already knew humans were foolish.
Um...
I'm sorry, ma'am, but like...
I'm sorry.
You're...
You are...
You're hot, but I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Your ID was just not good enough, ma'am.
Please don't hurt me.
No, she was...
Oh, hey.
She's back.
She's fucking back.
Okay.
7-9...
It's the same one.
Okay.
She came back and brought a different ID.
Sorry, ma'am.
It's still not the right ID.
I'm sorry.
It's still...
It's not the right ID, ma'am.
Ain't no way.
She escaped death.
Alright, who's next?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Let me...
Alright, round 3.
7-9-8-6-5-4-2...
Okay.
She brought the right ID this time.
We did it, guys.
She brought the right one.
Alright.
This all looks appropriate.
Let me double check your...
Your appearance real quick.
Okay.
Can you talk real fast?
Seems they don't work well.
Can't see my ID is purple.
Woah, don't fucking give me a good time, ma'am.
Just got...
Got her identity stolen.
Alright.
5-2-4-1.
5...
2-4-1.
Alright.
Okay, there's the husband.
Okay.
Oh yeah, they did forget their entry request.
Yeah, right?
Wait.
They forgot their entry at home.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Bro!
Wait a minute.
Again?
Ma'am, you gotta stop trying.
Ma'am, please.
She got the correct ID.
At least she got the right ID this time.
The fourth time.
I swear to God.
She comes in and it's her again.
What?
The fourth...
The fourth time's the charm.
Okay, here's her ID.
Okay, there she forgot her entry.
It's a cycle.
It never ends.
Alright.
We got her ID.
Yet again.
9-7-9-8-6-5-4-2-9-8.
Okay.
Everything...
Alright, let's see.
Everything seems to look correct this time.
This has never...
Okay.
Yeah, alright.
Everything looks like it's correct.
We did not fuck it up.
5-2-4-1-5-2- 4 -1.
Alright.
Did she come back yet?
Alright, she didn't.
Alright, they did forget it.
Okay, alright.
I think you're the right one.
I'm pretty sure you're the right one.
Okay, let me double check.
Yep, shark teeth.
Alright, yep.
Perhaps you're more or less simply cannot...
I don't know, I've just seen you too many times.
I had to make sure.
Alright, come right in.
We got the right one, guys.
We got the right one.
It only took four tries.
Oh, shit.
Okay, hey.
Oh my god.
Hey, kinky.
You're a milkman.
Alright.
Abuseous morale.
Where does he live again?
I don't remember.
It's the first floor, right?
763...
76478...
Mutilator.
3155...
3...
155...
Just to make sure.
Is nightmare mode endless?
Or is it like per round?
Just like the first one.
Okay, he's not home.
I mean, you look correct.
You have two pierced.
Oh, you have more than two.
He's breathing very heavily, too.
Yeah.
I'm a little uncomfortable with how heavy he's breathing, but yeah.
Yeah, he seems very excited.
That's for sure.
Yes, no, yes.
Yes.
Right here.
He's breathing very heavily right now.
He's getting a little too antsy.
Alright.
Goodbye, milkman.
Oh.
Barbados.
Alright.
How would it mean?
I guess nightmare would just be like the horns, too?
I mean, all the horns look like it's correct.
And then the...
Oh, greetings.
Hey, that's me.
I'm mortal.
Wait, I'm immortal?
I'm immortal here?
Okay.
Damn.
Job market is fucking rough.
Job market is so fucking rough, man.
Barabam.
Human hunter?
Oh, shit.
Wait, I'm human.
Wait.
I couldn't get a real job back in the human world?
8662?
I got him, right?
Okay, is your dad home?
Okay.
Alright, yeah, alright.
That's fine.
Everything looks great.
Barbados.
Uh...
Triple D, triple D.
Yeah, come right in.
You don't have your ID, but everything else looks good.
I did it.
Did I do my job correctly?
Okay, elephant man.
Chognar.
Okay.
He has two piercings, four...
Uh...
Four there.
I mean, you look correct.
Do you have anything?
For me?
Oh, he doesn't.
Okay, all I have is the ID.
Okay, where did you live?
The fuck do you live?
My god.
Oh, there he is.
Chognar.
Fine.
Four, five, six, nine, eight...
Oh, so he... Okay, big...
Okay.
Um...
I don't know.
It looks... You look like him.
Don't you like it when your doorman be like, I don't know.
When your doorman just be like, I don't know.
Three, two, one, five.
I love it when my doorman tells me he doesn't know.
Call Justin Case.
Okay.
Alright, he's not... Yes, they forgot their entry request.
Yeah, that seems right.
You forgot your entry request too.
Alright, come right in.
Alright.
I should be doing a great job.
Oh.
Wait, this is bad.
Oh, wait.
Three...
Six, three, two...
Wait.
Oh!
Oh, you're right!
It expired!
Wait, what?
Is he gaslighting me?
It's like, I could rip your eyes out.
My ID is...
Wait, he's gaslighting me.
Wait a minute.
That's it.
No gaslighters allowed.
I was like, it's perfect?
Am I wrong?
He can gaslight?
In this monster filled apartment building?
Behold my presence, human.
Wait, you're not on the list.
Oh, man.
I hate it when that happens too, sir.
I understand, man.
I mean, I would like it if they summoned me back to the human world.
That would be pretty awesome.
You know, I've been stuck here for a while.
Soul devourer.
Three, three, two, five, six, nine, nine, four, five.
In 1970 at Triple D's.
I come from my job as a soul devourer.
Imagine your job is the fucking soul devourer.
Sir Beth and Sir... Oh, wait, name's wrong.
It's Sir Zez Beth and Zez Beth.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm getting gaslit by these monsters and I almost believe them.
Get out of here.
I wonder how much it pays to be a soul devourer.
I wonder if it has a good 401.
What do you mean?
It literally said Sir Beth.
Yay!
I did it!
That one was easy.
Nightmare completed.
Wait, I got like perfect.
Let's go.
Nightmare completed.
Let's fucking go.
I'm fucking insane at this game.
Wait, that was fun.
Oh my god, I enjoyed it.
Perfect score.
I mean, I can do another clown.
Wait, what's this?
Do a clown.
Let's play a game.
You know what?
I know how to play.
Let's beat the clown before we call it.
J.
J diamond.
Let's go low.
We go low first.
Four.
Three.
Five.
Wait, he's going really fast.
No.
No, don't have it.
Yay!
Wait, can I do anything?
Oh, I can do five.
Nine.
J.
Bam!
I win.
I'm so good at card games, guys.
This is like what I do during my downtime as a doorman.
I just fall asleep and play cards with an evil clown.
Sounds about right.
I just...
I go to sleep and I just play cards with an evil clown.
Wait, I think he might win this.
JK, I'm better.
What?!
No way!
Okay, I'm gonna keep this.
Okay, we start low.
You fucker!
You actual fucker!
We'll start low.
How does he
have a plus one?!
Wait, that's actually cheating!
Okay, I have to make him get put one.
There's no way.
Oh, thank god.
Are you serious?!
There's no way!
Oh, okay.
Okay, we're fucking each other over.
Are you serious?!
No way!
There's no way!
Oh my god.
Oh, no.
No.
No!
Please!
I'm lost!
No!
I got clowned!
Bad dream!
Oh, I'm so good at Dota.
That's not fair!
He got me!
He actually got me!
I can't believe it!
I worked so hard as a Dwarven!
And the clown had to beat me up at my game!
That's not fair!
Ended on a loss.
I lost my firstborn child to the clown.
Anyway, that's fun though.
It's nice seeing, checking out.
That's not Night Neighbour.
I thought it would be a little more harder.
Because people were saying it's like Papers, Please, but it definitely was an easier version of Papers, Please.
I don't understand why it has a cult...
But wait, I don't understand though why the Milkman has a cult following.
I don't understand how the Milkman has a cult following.
That's the one thing I don't understand.
Look at him!
He's the Milkman!
Guys, you don't...
No, Doki.
You don't understand.
But I had a great time checking it out.
Alright, but before I go...
Before I go, it's time to show!
Yes!
Buy my merch!
So as you can see, we do have our Good Smile plushies.
The pre-orders are closed, but we still have pre-orders going for the...
Oh wait, no.
Not this one.
Sorry, I put...
There's no giveaways over, by the way.
Sorry, this...
Giveaways has been over, but we still have official YouTube plushies out.
I'll post a link in chat real quick.
But yeah, I think we have three weeks left for the pre-orders, so please check them out if you wish to support me and my stream and also for future merch opportunities.
I really do appreciate it.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sim for the tired minimum wage man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, I know there is a birthday super chat as you all know that.
I know that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi Doki, it's my birthday and I just want to send a small super to thank you for your streams.
From my evolution from a dragoon into a bird, I shall return to lurking, enjoying every moment.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
And a happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Xenona!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Okay, so, oh yeah.
Um...
Uh...
What was I gonna say?
Oh yes, and tomorrow I will be doing errands again.
So, I will make sure I'll buy another desktop confessional tomorrow, guys.
I promise.
And then we'll check it out live on stream tomorrow if it works.
If what?
I'll buy two!
I'll buy two and then maybe in the future I'll sign the ones that don't work and then I don't know, do a giveaway or some shit.
What the fuck am I gonna do with three broken ones?
I'll buy two and then I'll sign the one that doesn't work and you can't do a giveaway or charity auction.
I'm gonna do two pulls!
I'll do a two pull.
I'm not gonna buy ten confessionals!
What am I gonna do with ten desktop confessionals?
The light works, guys.
No, it's not that.
There's just no holy voice, okay?
The lights work, though, at least.
At least the lights work.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna call it here.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Oh, the AmiAmi one?
Oh, you still wanna get the Good Smile plushies?
AmiAmi still has pre-orders up.
Yeah!
Oh, I didn't know that!
Beeps!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
But yes, if you still want the Good Smile plushie, the AmiAmi one's still pre-ordered over there.
Anyway, guys, I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!
Also, secret... Oh, sorry.
Wrong chat thingy.
But secret ending!
Secret ending!
You can tell my voice is getting better and better slowly, so I hope by next week, I'll be able to I'll be able to do longer Zatsudon's after streams again.
Obviously, I can't do long chatting streams after stream because of my voice recovering and my throat recovering, but I hope that maybe by next week, I can start doing again.
Anyway, guys, I'll see you guys next time.
Bye!